how dope would it be as if after the big  fights and there's controversy with the  judging  you're allowed they put like four to  five media members who the ufc can  choose which they do anyway they choose  and they ask questions like why did you  do this  explain this these guys get half their  pays when these shitty judges just shoot  from the hip and don't know what they're  watching the ufc just goes oh that's  judging don't move to the hands of the  scorecard you're like  what the guy i'm in the toughest biggest  league in the world and i i can't depend  on judges to me it's the biggest  biggest  uh  blind spot the ufc has not to do  something about it